zu Gast bei uns ist jetzt Markus Keim
Sicherheitsexperte von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik ein schönen
guten Morgen nun vermeldete gestern die
ukrainische Regierung weitere
Geländegewinne im Süden und Osten der
Ukraine auch die strategisch wichtige
Stadt vollständig befreit worden sein
nun sind das ja alles Teile die Russland
für sich beansprucht was bedeutet das
jetzt wie wird Putin darauf reagieren
auf Kriegshandlungen in seinem
vermeintlich eigenen Revier also so
merkwürdig das klingt im Moment bedeutet
es noch gar nicht die Ukraine hat sich
von ihrem militärischen Planung nicht
abbringen lassen wir sehen ein Dynamik
zugunsten der Ukraine seit etwa vier
Wochen die setzt sich ungebrochen vor
und sie haben es angesprochen es gibt
Geländegewinne im Osten und im Südosten
und aus ukrainischer Sicht gibt es
keinen Anlass aufgrund der Annexion
aufgrund der steinreferent davon Abstand
zu nehmen und es macht im Moment
zumindest jetzt nicht den Eindruck als
würde Russland das als anders für eine
weitere Eskalation nehmen also trotz des
politischen Getöses den letzten Wochen
auf dem Boden militärisch sehen wir
eigentlich genau dasselbe was glauben
sie
denn da bin ich noch ein bisschen
vorsichtig also die Dynamik weist in
diese Richtung und das hat ja auch für
viel Freude und Genugtuung in westlichen
Hauptstädten gesorgt aber jetzt bereits
zu verkünden die Ukraine wieder in Krieg
gewinnen das scheint mir ein bisschen
verfrüht angesichts der
Entschlossenheit die Präsident Putin ja
auch mit der Annexion unter Beweis
stellt ich glaube wir müssen uns auf
einen längeren Krieg einstellen sie
haben es eben Getöse genannt Putin droht
ja jetzt immer wieder auch mit Atom
Angriffen oder dem zu einer Atombombe
für wie realistisch halten Sie denn
solchen Atomangriff das ist die Frage
aller Fragen die wir uns ja seit Monaten
stellen was passiert im Kopf von
Präsident Putin ich kann da auch nicht
reinschauen aber ich finde es zumindest
jetzt zum gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt eher
unwahrscheinlich weil es doch nicht mit
der russischen nuklear doktrine in einen
in Übereinstimmung zu bringen ist das
Nuklearwaffen nur bei der akuten
Bedrohung des russischen Staates
eingesetzt werden und man müsste ja auch
hinzufügen sollte gesehen Putin
Nuklearwaffen einsetzen wäre eine
internationaler Pavia also auch seine
momentanen Verbündeten wenn man von den
entsprechen will China würden nichts
mehr mit ihm zu tun haben wollen und für
die russische Bevölkerung würde klar
werden es ist keine spezialoperation
sondern ein Krieg was ich ohnehin schon
andeutet damit wäre das auch
innenpolitisch alles die legitimiert
sprich sie
halten peinlich zumindest ist um
gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt jetzt sind
gestern wohl die ersten Rekruten der
teilmobil-machung in der Ukraine
eingetroffen wird das denn den
Kriegsverlauf zugunsten Russlands
verändern ich bin dann auch sehr
zurückhaltend weil wir stellen doch fest
und das ist finde ich eine
bemerkenswerte Einsicht der letzten
Monate dass eine Demokratie wie die
Ukraine besser kämpft als ein
autoritäres System die Entscheider sind
besser informiert die Soldaten und
Soldaten sind dadurch gekennzeichnet
dass sie eine bessere Moral an den Tag
legen Sie wissen wofür sie kämpfen
nämlich für die Freiheit ihres Landes
das ist bei den russischen Soldaten
nicht der Fall wir stellen fest dass es
ein großes Problem mit Moral gibt mit
Logistik mit desertüren und anderen mehr
also die Zahl von 300.000 die angestrebt
wird ist ja noch gar nicht erreicht also
die Probleme der russischen Streitkräfte
setzen sich fort von daher glaube ich
nicht dass der angestrebte Effekt so
schnell eintritt schauen wir noch mal
auf einen anderen Krisenherd kurz
nämlich den im Iran da wird auch für die
Freiheit und die Selbstbestimmung
gekämpft spätestens genau seit dem Tod
von Massa Amini der Studentin die ums
Leben kam glauben Sie dass diese
Proteste dem Regime gefährlich werden
könnten also sie sind ja schon
gefährlich wenn man sich den Umfang
anguckt also heute morgen habe ich
Schätzung gelesen 100 Monate 30 000 100
130 Tote sind so beklagen die Bilder von
gestern mit den Übergriffen in den in
den Universitäten sind bedrückend und
wir stellen ja fest dass jetzt große
Bevölkerung Schichten von den Unruhen
die gestartet sind als Unruhen gegen die
Bekleidungsvorschriften jetzt
eingebunden worden sind in diese Unruhen
die sie jetzt gegen das Regime richten
von daher ist das eine Bedrohung aber
die das Vorgehen der Sicherheitskräfte
ist sehr nennen das mal robust gewaltsam
und ich sehe im Moment noch nicht eine
Massenbewegung die das System
hinwegfegen würde
was meinen Sie denn wie sollte sich
jetzt Deutschland und auch der Westen
positionieren oder Verhalten während
weitere Sanktionen angebracht die sind
ja schon in Vorbereitung die EU Bräter
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe
heute über weitere Sanktionen das ist so
unbefriedigend das ist auch eine ganz
wenigen Hebel denen die EU und die
deutsche Politik in der Hand hat weil
wir haben ja nichts zum ersten Mal oder
ständig zum ersten Mal fest dass unsere
Einwirkungsmöglichkeiten auf die
politischen Zustände in anderen Ländern
sehr begrenzt sind das muss man so zur
Kenntnis nehmen und von daher sind
Sanktion glaube ich das richtige Mittel
vielen Dank Markus Keim für die
Einschätzungen sehr gerne